>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Stephen King: Hello, I'm
Stephen King and I'm here
to kick off the Library of Congress
Literacy Awards by issuing this call
to nominate a group in your town
- wherever you are in the world -
that is doing great work
to promote literacy.
Illiteracy remains an enormous
problem around the world -
757 million adults cannot read
or write a simple sentence.
61 million elementary
school-age children
around the world are not in school.
In the United States, 34 percent
of the children entering
kindergarten do not have the basic
language skills to learn to read.
No one person or group is
going to move the needle alone.
But together, we can
make a difference.
That's why I am joining
the Library of Congress
in supporting the thousands of
organizations around the world
that are working to
promote literacy.
Every year through the generosity
of David M. Rubenstein the Library
of Congress Literacy Program
honors 15 to 20 agencies
and awards hundreds of thousands of
dollars in support of replicating,
expanding or promoting
their outstanding work.
Nominate them now at loc.gov/read.
Then, go find something
good to read.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.